Die nasa schlägt einen revolutionären antrieb für raumschiffe
vorstadt chemische antriebe bei denen unmengen an treibstoff transportiert werden müssen schlagen sie
einen photonen antrieb vor mit ihm könnten
Relativistische geschwindigkeiten erreicht werden die deutlich höher als sie der chemischen
raketenantriebe werden wie funktioniert das jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Raketenantriebe haben einen fast schon tragische
Nebeneffekt umso weiter und schneller ich reisen möchte desto mehr treibstoff muss ich mitnehmen um so mehr treibstoff
Ich brauche also mit. Nehme desto mehr treibstoff brauche ich auch
Um wiederum diesen treibstoff zu transportieren und so weiter und so fort es ist ein fast jedes ziel umso mehr treibstoff
ich brauche desto mehr treibstoff brauche ich
Für einen mars-flug sind so wahre unmengen nötig damit das überhaupt klappt müssen die missionen wie die zum mars auch
Im weltraum betankt werden bzw dort müssen tanks gesammelt werden und anders raum schrift montiert werden ein wahnsinniger aufwand deshalb schickt die nasa
einen photonen antrieb vor er kommt ohne
Treibstoff an bord aus dabei werden am raumschiff sonnensegel montiert die von der erde aus mit lasern beschossen werden oder von
Satelliten in der erdumlaufbahn und so innerhalb kürzester zeit werden sie auf extrem. Hohe geschwindigkeiten
beschleunigt seine technik wie sie auch für das break star
schott projekt geplant ist bei dem mini sondern auch vor geschwindigkeiten beschleunigt werden sollen um dann unser nächstes
Sternensystem alpha centauri innerhalb von 20 jahren zu erreichen da vermuten wir ja mögliches
außerirdisches leben aber auch hier
im sonnensystem könnte die technik für deutlich schnellere flüge zwischen den planeten genutzt werden der leitende physiker der
machbarkeitsstudie die zurzeit entsteht ist philipp lubin von der university of california in santa barbara zitat
elektromagnetische beschleunigung ist nuss und grenzt durch die lichtgeschwindigkeit
chemische systeme sind begrenzt durch die menge an energie die durch die chemischen prozesse erzeugt werden
zitat ende der treibstoff ist also das nadelöhr der bisherigen konventionellen
antrieb rubin setzt deshalb auf photonen antrieb kern des systems ist ein sogenanntes die star for system
es kann die energie von 50 atomkraftwerken für einen laser bereitstellen damit kann es
asteroiden abwehren oder eben auch raumschiffe antreiben beim break star
show project sollen damit wenige gramm schwere mini sonden auf 26 prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
beschleunigt werden sie könnten dann in knapp 20 jahren alpha centauri
erreichen zwei nachteile hat diese idee sie würden wahnsinnig schnell durch das sternsystem
rasen und könnten nur sehr kurz daten erheben und sie könnten auch nur minimale funktionen haben weil sie so klein sehen zum beispiel könnte
Jede sonne zum beispiel nur nur ein foto machen und zur erde
Funkte es geht aber in unserem sonnensystem auch anders größere sonden und nicht ganz so
geschwindigkeiten ein 100 kilogramm schweres raumschiff könnte zum beispiel auf ein prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
beschleunigt werden und den mars so in drei tagen erreichen die raumsonde voyager die als erste sonde bisher in den interstellaren raum
Außerhalb unseres sonnensystems erreicht hat die könnte innerhalb von wenigen tagen überholt werden und so weiter und so fort lookeen arbeitet
im moment weiter an seiner machbarkeitsstudie
Ich bin extrem gespannt wie hoch die kosten für ein solches projekt werden und wie schnell es
Umsetzbar wäre also sobald es neues gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn er die weiterentwicklung nicht verpassen wollt dann drückt man hier ein aber
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch über neue themen informiert, er geht es weiter
also einfach drauf kriegen mit reise zu aliens nur
20 jahre zum nächsten stern wo ich mich näher mit dem projekt break star schott befassen also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt